while the leaders of Brazil India China
and South Africa will attend the 15th
brick summer to Johannesburg in person
Russian President Vladimir Putin will
participate virtually it follows an
international criminal Court warrant for
the Russian Leader's arrest related to
alleged war crimes in Ukraine finding
itself in illegal bind the South African
government announced last month Putin
would not attend instead foreign
minister Sergey lavrov will take his
place
plans to expand the block are expected
to be high on the agenda at least 23
countries including Iran and Argentina
have formally applied to join bricks
while larger economies China and Russia
support the move there's some
disagreement I think that has got to do
with the the incomes of the brics
countries themselves because South
Africa being the smallest economy in
brics has often been seen as an
appendage so to say and the fact that
South Africa's admission to the brics in
2008 was largely seen as China's agenda
not a consensus by all the British
countries so I think that is why India
would be very much equivocal but the
consensus amongst all in the majority of
the brics countries is that yes an
expansion is really timely member states
represent 40 percent of the world's
population and their combined GDP
accounts for almost a third of the
global economy the summit's theme is
brics and Africa highlighting the
potential for the block to build
relations on a continent that's
increasingly becoming a stage for
competition between world powers it's
also an opportunity for brics members to
present themselves as alternative
development Partners to Western Nations
the block aims to better represent
developing nations by increasing
industrialization and infrastructure
development in Africa and ultimately
expanding trade and investment being
part of brics we are close to a
conversation with the economies that are
going to drive Global growth and there
in obviously shortens the distance
between those markets and African
products so the association is important
that we stay within it and obviously now
that we are in the the Block it's an
opportunity for us to highlight African
Services African Goods African trade
patterns and find a way of getting our
products and our goods and services into
these big markets the Gathering is
likely to continue discussions about a
new currency to rival the dominance of
the US dollar China will want to
strengthen geopolitical ties at a time
of tensions with the us while for Russia
the block is a way of overcoming Global
isolation caused by its war in Ukraine
all Partners will be hoping this Summit
ends with concrete resolutions
Johannesburg
foreign